في اعقاب رحلته غير المعلنه الى كييف حضر
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اجتماع مجموعه
بوخارست 9 في بولندا والخاص بدول الجناح
الشرقي لحلف شمال الاطلسي وهناك قال ان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ارتكب خطا فادحا
بتعليق مشاركه روسيا في معاهده ستارت
الجديده للحد من الاسلحه النوويه داعيا
الى حشد الدعم لاوكرانيا
بصفتكم الجناح الشرقيه للناتو فانتم في
الخطوط الاماميه لدفاعنا الجماعي وتعرفون
اننا على المحك في هذا الصراع يضم
الاجتماع دولا من وسط وشرق اوروبا وهي
بلغاريا وجمهوريه التشيك واستونيا والمجر
اضافه الى لاتفيا وبولندا ورومانيا
تم تشكيل المجموعه في عام 2015 بعد ان
استولت روسيا على شبه جزيره القرم ومعظم
الاعضاء هم الان من بين اقوى المؤيدين
للمساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
تتمتع دول الجناح الشرقي بالحمايه اكثر من
اي وقت مضى لقد اجتزنا معا اختبار التضامن
والانسانيه بسبب مساعدتنا لاوكرانيا
من بين المجتمعين دول تؤيد دعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا ما عدا المجر وبلغاريا اللتان
تعتقدان ان دعمها سيطيل امد الحرب فيما حث
حلف شمال الاطلسي على ضروره مواصله الوقوف
الى جانبك
لا يمكننا السماح لروسيا بالاستمرار في
تقويد الامن الاوروبي يجب كسر حلقه
العدوان الروسي
اجتماع الجناح الشرقي للحلف لتاكيد
الالتزامات المتبادله داخل الناتو بدعم
اوكرانيا فيما قال الكرملين انه يعتبر حلف
شمال الاطلسي تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وهو
الذي قد يتوسع قريبا ليشمل السويد وفنل